Just to get started.
Anyone who hasn't heard of WebAssembly?
Great.
Anyone here who has had a reason to use WebAssembly
in a production app?
All right.
So we are all about on the same page.
I would like to invite you back into journey
of time to the year 2017.
Like most of you, I heard about WebAssembly
but beyond surface level stuff I didn't know
much about it.
I read this headline and thought huh, I guess
if WebAssembly really does kill JavaScript
I will figure that stuff out but it seems
like people have wanted JavaScript to die
for a while and we are still here.
What does a typical web dev need Wasm for?
I work for a consulting firm based in Seattle
called GEN/UI.
I think our dev manager described it best
when he said our web expertise is in doing
something weird.
We built a screen recording and editing app
for Chrome OS that runs entirely client-side.
Our requirements were as follows: The app
was meant to look and feel like it was native
to Chrome OS and act as a competitor to others
out there.
The client requested the video provided video
editing capability and needed to run locally
offline.
There are a couple ways to develop for Chrome
OS and we decided to use Chrome package OS
and they are essentially web apps given additional
hardware APIs.
As we started to investigate how we wanted
to implement the project, it was a surprise
to discover how much it is possible to do
with media in native JavaScript.
For instance, if the user consents, you can
capture their whole screen or Webcam and use
the native recorder API to record the screen,
create a video and allow the user to download
it to their machine.
That is possible in any modern web browser.
There is nothing special about Chromebook
that lets you do it.
If all we needed was a screen recording app
we would be set with those tools but the client
had requested some video editing capabilities.
As a result, we started to get into a realm
of things that are technically possible in
JavaScript that is just not a great idea for
a variety of reasons.
For instance, if you wanted to create a water
mark you can create a media stream that collects
data from a canvas element.
You can then draw your watermark on to every
frame of that canvas element and merge it
into the stream from your screen recording
but unsurprisingly it is too memory intensive.
The resulting videos were kind of like watching
a very badly dubbed foreign film.
You have got all the pieces there but they
don't line up.
Another video editing feature we wanted to
implement was trimming or shortening the video.
It turns out you can actually do that in plain
JavaScript so long as you only want to trim
the end of the video.
If you want to trim the beginning, you are
out of luck, at least in Chrome.
That brings us to functionality that simply
isn't possible in native JavaScript.
Once you create that WebM file you are done.
There is no way to add a watermark or filter
after the fact and it isn't possible to re-encode
the video.
The media recorder API gives you a WebM so
if you want a gif or MP4 you can't do that
with native functionality.
At this point, we went back to the client
and recommended a server-side only solution.
There are two big reasons for this.
Video editing is a memory intensive process
and Chromebooks are meant to do most work
from the Cloud by design.
And client side video editing pushes the limits
on what is possible today.
We had two people working on this without
an infinite budget.
The client asked us to move ahead with a client-side
only implementation eventually.
This set us off on the journey of determining
what is possibly limiting.
We determined video editing isn't possible
in native JavaScript we needed to find a way
to run a code that is not native JavaScript.
Running non-JS code in a browser has a long
history.
Anyone remember this thing called Flash?
Anyone?
It is kind of obscure.
Any ActionScript devs out there?
Any OUBT about Silver Light?
You may have heard WebAssembly isn't just
another way to write plugins and that is true
but without understanding more about plugins
in general it is hard to know why the comparison
is made.
The '90s are in again.
Let's go back to 1995.
We are all wearing JNCOs and the Slater guy
is this guy.
Your browser of choice is Netscape and they
just released the Netscape plugin API or NP
API which was the first way to develop plugins
or browser extension and handle media from
within the browser.
What happened was the browser would come across
content it couldn't handle and detect the
file type and load the appropriate plugins
that will run in place on your web page.
As of today, NP API is deprecated in every
browser.
That is because the Advent of HTML5 means
the browser can handle a lot of things natively
that would otherwise have been handled by
plugins.
Plugins didn't actually fully die with NP
API.
Google released the pepper API which is a
build chain that produces binary file types
native client or pepper native.
It was meant to provide a more secure, less
complex alternative to NP API.
You can recompile libraries written in C or
C++ and that could be run within the browser
and accessed in JavaScript.
For the WebAssembly fans in the crowd this
may sound familiar.
Why aren't we talking about pepper and how
it harkens the death of the most widely used
program language?
An open standard for pepper was not created
and they were only supported on Chrome, Chromium
and blink-base browsers.
Portable native client is deprecated for every
platform except Chromebook but we were building
for Chromebooks so let's put a pen in that.
WebAssembly, like portable native client,
takes advantage of common hardware capabilities
to deliver native or near native performance
and allows libraries written in C, C++ and
rest into a Wasm format.
Developers can write directly in WebAssembly
for the super nerds out there.
Unlike pepper WebAssembly is an open standard
and has been adopted by every modern browser.
It is really something that you can use and
deliver to the vast majority of the web.
That doesn't actually say so much about what
is great about WebAssembly in the first place,
or why we would want to use C or C++.
There are a couple reasons why you might use
WebAssembly in your application.
The first of these is performance.
Performance on WebAssembly is faster than
native JavaScript and that is mostly due to
a lack of dynamic typing in WebAssembly.
You might look into WebAssembly if you have
a particularly heavy operation you could perform
in JavaScript but prefer not to.
Every single page web application framework
has a DOM diffing operation.
It is a heavy thing to do and it can have
negative performance implications for updating
your page particularly in component-heavy
scenario.
Glimmer, which is the DOM rendering engine
by the Ember team has an existing build that
leverages WebAssembly for this purpose and
that is a methodology that should result in
a much faster rendering engine.
I am definitely not saying that because of
the primary architecture of Glimmer is speaking
later today.
There are folks looking into this as well
for React.
Performance aside, the second reason you may
want to use Wasm speaks to video editing.
You cannot edit video in JavaScript but you
can edit video in C++.
You can do several things in C++ or Rest like
video editing, platform immolation and games.
Wasm was built for our use case and we needed
to choose a video editing library we can use.
It was important to find a library because
there were only two of us and we had neither
the budget or expertise to build something
from scratch.
It turns out there are not tons of video editing
options in C++ or Rust and that may be due
to FFmpeg which is a command line tool that
supports adding watermark or tripping or cropping
video or anything you might want to do with
it.
FFmpeg could be used through portable native
client or WebAssembly and we were unable to
find another good candidate.
The first thing we did was go to the mpm registry
and there is an FFmpeg.
I am grateful to the author of this package
and the person who forked it and added extra
documentation.
Without these folks, we would have been lost
but these were enough bread crumbs for us
to figure out how to do this.
Getting back to my MPM install.
I saw a couple concerning things off the bat.
First is the size.
The entirety of FFmpeg is about 15 bytes and
that is a lot to load and a lot to ask of
users to download.
The default build includes tons of functionality
we didn't plan on using.
It also includes the H2-64 kodak which was
still pat patented.
This is an old version, also.
We came to the conclusion there is an existing
MPM install for this library, but we needed
to compile our own Wasm file.
This is the point at which we started to get
into technologies that JS devs don't tend
to use on a day to day basis and the first
is called Emscripten.
For those that haven't done a lot of this
thing it is vaguely analogous to a tool like
Babel.
It takes uncompiled C++ library and builds
it in a way that a Wasm is produced.
You can pass in various build options.
If you want to build your Wasm binary in a
way it is compatible with web workers you
will do that as part of the overall Emscripten
and build command.
That is a lot of high level information.
Let's bring it down.
The following example is a little hello, world
written in C. Like most of you I don't program
in C# but the main method is what runs when
the app loads.
We imported the standard input and output
library.
In a C# application this prints to the console
and in our app prints to the JavaScript console
but we will display it in the DOM also.
Now we need to compile our hello world to
a Wasm file.
You can do that in Emscripten with the following
command.
You can see we do need to specify Wasm and
that is because Emscripten can compile to
other formats too.
And dash 0 output to HTML lets us know I want
Emscripten to build the page rather than just
compile a binary.
Let's look at the web page.
There is a lot more going on than just LEL
hello world.
The default gives you a page with a console
you can use to see the Wasm output and it
has JavaScript glue code.
If this was a Thanksgiving turkey drawing
tutorial we are at this strep drawing an outline
of the hand.
You know what comes next?
We don't need hello, world.
We need FFmpeg and there are a few steps in
between.
It is worth just trying here to convert FFmpeg
and see what happens next.
Make is a Unix tool.
And clang is a front end compilation for interface
and gcc is the GNU/Unix.
This is the root folder of the FFmpeg library.
We need to use the project's make file and
substitute cling and gcc with the own Emscripten
build tool.
Piece of cake.
In case you thought it was cake, let me assure
you it isn't.
Emscripten built their own tool to help you
substitute for clang and gcc.
It is called M con emconfigure.
We will run emmake make and that should build
the library into the format and bit code.
Assuming everything is well, we can run a
command similar to the hello, world command
from earlier but of course, everything hasn't
gone well.
After about 20 minutes of compilation, emmake
make has an error generating deep from within
the heart of this massive library.
Anyone who has struggled to get builds to
translate knows the pain that can accompany
production builds particularly as they become
more complex.
Building a project in C# isn't different and
compiling tat project into a format it was
never intended for adds a greater degree of
complexity.
Looking at the hello, world.
C from earlier it seems reasonable to debug
the process even though we are not C# developers.
It didn't see reasonable to debug this giant
make file and dive in the heart of this legacy
framework.
Emconfigure makes assumptions about your C#
base build environment that may not be true.
It was necessary to go in and replace every
reference to the existing build change.
Emscripten can't use anything using ASM and
that is used in any C# libraries to provide
compiler instructions to gcc.
Since we are not building with gcc we need
to pass the option to build without this.
And finally, Emscripten will not convert every
possible application.
In the end we prevailed.
Here we are looking at a video that has been
created in native JavaScript through a screen
recording of a YouTube clip.
Our media recorder returned a blob we can
convert to a file and save to the user's local
machine.
You will notice we cannot seek through the
video and this is due to a Chrome-specific
bug where their mediator recorder doesn't
create key frames as it reports therefore
the find of file created doesn't know important
things.
The client wanted to add trim functionality
to the app and that makes total sense.
We have started screen recordings for getting
to set-up our screen and needing to trim out
the first bit.
This is where FFmpeg comes in handy.
If we run our FFmpeg we will ask it to trim
to the desired length.
I compiled my FFmpeg build, create a new web
worker and listen to make sure that worker
is ready, once everything is loaded I will
post a message containing all the information
that FFmpeg needs to kick off a trim operation.
We can see the type of thing I want to run
is called run and that is the default or main
method in FFmpeg and I have passed in data
which is actually an array buffer.
Finally, I pass in the same arguments I would
pass in if I were using FFmpeg from the command
line.
We have got a dash-SS where you start the
video.
Dash T is how long the video is.
Dash c copy means to use the existing kodak.
Let's see what that looks like.
I kicked off the FFmpeg by default in the
background and we can see before too long
we get a little video.
It is different than it was before.
It is only two seconds long.
That being said, there are some important
caveats for using this technology.
The last video editing feature was to provide
crop and that is in case the user wants to
only display a portion of what they have created
in their video.
You can see we have kicked off our operation,
we are getting lots of logging output from
FFmpeg and that is great.
We know something is happening but that video
is only a minute long and we are still watching
it convert so we can't put that in front of
the user, obviously.
The other options were really fast?
What is up?
I told you performance in WebAssembly is supposed
to be much better, right?
There are two things happening here that cause
performance issues.
One is just that re-encoding takes a little
more time than copying the exist code act.
This operation would be a little slower from
the command line but not by a factor of about
a 1,000 which is what we have here.
It turns out when Emscripten provides the
conversion there are a few patterns in C++
that convert but have implications.
Code that relies on X86 behavior.
And yes, I had to look at stuff up there.
In theory, could we address these performance
issues and patch them in the same way we watch
the code causing conversion problems?
Or add in WebAssembly specific composition
applications to compensate?
The truth is I don't know.
We did haven't the budget to become all-knowing
video Wasm encoding masters and who does,
really?
It is worth mentioning when WebAssembly shipped
to all browsers it shipped as an MVP.
A ton of functionality is coming down the
pipeline that might help support the issues
we had with FFmpeg and one is multi-threaded
support.
Wasm is looking to support garbage collection
will opens the doors beyond C++ and Rust.
Since we were on the Chromebook platform we
looked at using the pepper build change and
an FFmpeg process is defined there and the
result is quite a bit faster than our WebAssembly
binary.
Perhaps, unsurprisingly, the performance heavy
conversions take time and produce an unacceptable
user experience on the Chromebooks due to
their lightweight processor.
Is this a story on why you should not use
WebAssembly?
Not at all.
We learned a lot and I want to share those
takeaways.
First, FFmpeg was the wrong library to learn
about WebAssembly and C++ in the first place.
If you are evaluating a new C++ library you
think you mind like to use there are well-known
patterns you can check for to give you a good
idea about whether you should proceed.
Portability guidelines can be found on the
Emscripten website.
This is where it is good idea to have someone
with C++ expertise to determine if your library
contains these and how difficult it is to
patch them.
The Rust language was designed with the web
in mind and looks to support Wasm.
If the functionality you are looking in exists
in C++ and Rust it is probably a good idea
to use Rust.
WebAssembly is helping pave the way to use
the browser as a true application platform.
For the average JavaScript converting into
Wasm is still a problem.
As Wasm becomes more mainstream, I expect
to see better tooling, more libraries and
simpler processes become more prevalent.
In the mean time we may all be consuming WebAssembly
in frameworks long before we ever have a reason
to create things ourselves.
Thank you.